If you can take a vacation between December and May,...
...visiting Chile with your friends or family can be a good decision.
Many travelers rave about the beauty of Patagonia...
...and the Iguassu Falls when they think of traveling to South America.
However, now there is another attraction equally magnificent.
A few years ago, in the most southern tip of South America,...
...in the Strait of Magellan, scientists made a great discovery.
They found the summer feeding grounds of humpback whales...
...in the channel around Carlos III Island.
They lobbied the government and finally Chile's first marine park,...
...Marine Park Francisco Coloane, was established.
Many visitors come to watch whales there.
You can also watch dolphins, penguins, birds and seals.
If you can really make it there, don't miss the chance to try kayaking.
This could be your favorite pastime in this region.
Wouldn't it be amazing to take a picture of you kayaking in such a beautiful surrounding?